hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
my game of the year for 2019 was the
sublime Resident Evil 2 remake and just
before the dust settles on the year
Capcom our by Jerry Playstations state
of play update resident evil 3 remake
was finally confirmed the trailer
revealed so much information which I
thought was worth breaking down so let's
get on this hype train and find 7 things
you need to know about Resident Evil 3
oh and if you didn't play Resident Evil
2 remake or you need a refresher I'll
link my playthrough for context here
from this point forward I'm gonna
presume you know about re 2 we are
starting with the return of Jill
Valentine she must be the greatest re
hero ever right who's your favorite I'll
be sure to be in the comments telling
you your rock it's still ok Jill is part
of the OG Resident Evil game the
original stars team member that makes it
back to Raccoon City just in time for
the zombie pandemic to ruin everything
if you played the original game in the
1990s you'll be able to spot all the
callbacks to the ps1 days but if you
don't I won't explain the importance of
shots like this it's better to find out
firsthand instead what I'll do is set
the scene resident evil 3 takes place
both before and after Resident Evil 2
that's why the trailer has shots of Leon
and data from the game we've already
played and that's why the timer goes
back in time the two stories run
alongside each other without the
characters ever really knowing even
though they tread the same paths for
example there's a nemesis shaped hole in
the upstairs of the police department in
Resident Evil 2 looks like we'll be
experiencing that very soon
just like last year's game Resident Evil
3 will have two playable characters but
in the original the second playable
character was not a separate scenario
you had to play through the game as Jill
Valentine to get hold of this new guy
maybe that will change here but back in
the 1990s it was a single main character
Jill as we're talking about him the
second character here is umbrella
biohazard countermeasure service member
Carlos Oliviero who is sent into the
city with his team to rescue civilians
the two work together to escape the city
or at least try to but he is where
things get freaky
remember the frightening mr. X from re -
well Jill's antagonist takes this to
another level
the Nemesis the Nemesis is a as a bio
experimental weapon that has a single
purpose here in Raccoon City to
eliminate all the stars team members and
right now there's only two in the city
Brad Vickers the team's helicopter pilot
and our hero Jill Valentine the Nemesis
will continuously hunt you down for the
entirety of the game making every corner
petrifying and every moment of calm
chilling as an extra point here some
people have suggested that mr. X will
also be here among Jill's case meaning
double the trouble for our heroine with
two presumably undefeatable behemoths on
her trail you're gonna feel anxiety
playing this game let's confirm that now
during the trailer a shot for only half
a second in length was on screen but
this confirms a returning enemy type if
you recognize this beast looks to me
like a hunter a humanoid reptile created
by umbrella these things were modern
deadly in the original games taking off
your head in a single swipe and unlike
zombies hunters can run and I mean
unnerving Lea first you will need an
adult diaper to play this game moving on
from the campaign Resident Evil games
have always done a great job in adding
replayable content Time Attack survivor
missions unlockable skins and weapons
but this time it's been taken to a new
level with the inclusion of the
asymmetric online multiplayer known as
resistance if you've played dead by
daylight if you've played Friday the
13th you already know what to expect
one player controls one of the super bio
weapons like the Nemesis or tyrant
and is tasked with hunting down for
survivors played by real-life humans
around the world but if we scratch the
surface a little more is more to this
game mode the mastermind has far more up
his sleeves than simply playing as a
tyrant they can use CCTV to monitor
survivors setting traps to slow their
progression the mastermind earns and
uses these cards to unleash chaos like
controlling a tyrant on the other side
the survivors must work together to
progress through stages obtaining
special items in the hopes of getting
through three stages and escaping this
horror each survivor has different perks
such as damage reduction healing options
hacking and so on that kind of thing
giving this mode a great deal of
replayability so when can we get our
hands on Resident Evil 3 and the
resistance online mode while not long at
all April the 3rd 2020 it's so damn
close from a development standpoint this
also confirms re 2 & 3 were remade at
the same time just like the stories they
tell in the games the fact she tells us
that resident evil 3 will release on ps4
Xbox one and PC through Steam but we
will have to wait to see if cross play
will be a thing for the online modes oh
and it's a horror game so expect 18 plus
content
are you happy youtube I have told
everyone this is an eighteen plus game
of course there's more pre-order bonuses
are beginning to be announced the day
one preorder bonus is the original skins
for Jill and Carlos Jill's iconic tube
top makes a return but Carlos looks more
like the character skin from Chronicles
diehard Resident Evil fans will struggle
to let this offer pass them by but I'm
trying my best to resist there was one
other thing I wanted to try and break
down but I can't figure it out I need
your help there's a shot in the trailer
which could be nothing at all or it
could be a clue take a look at this as
Jill enters the fire escape a figure can
be seen turning and running and they do
it incredibly fast what could this mean
I'll be in the comments looking for
direction please help me out or maybe my
mind is playing tricks on me and this
figure is not important at all what do
you think okay so I won't waste your
time anymore there's a super quick look
at the new trailer for Resident Evil 3
and the things you should know about the
game are you excited
for more zombie filled action and
terrifying survival because I am I
cannot wait I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade and Jill is the best character
in Resident Evil see you next time
[Music]